the russian team is so strong who could
that be i think those will be some of
the younger russian players there's
there's dozens of grand masters around
the age of artemis that might be alexei
serrano um a few other young guys there
but here we go here we go yeah meanwhile
the game it has been a queen's gambit
white offering opponent early stage and
black so far declined that gambit you
know he'll sense it and he'll try and
take advantage okay meanwhile flat just
developing his knight so not that
aggressive from black so far still
pretty solid cagey stuff
where will he try and imbalance the
position i was just going to say do you
think he will go for the kind of lavon
ironian approach develop his dark square
bishop out and pin the knight but he
says no
instead he develops his knight uh
favorite of vladimir kramnik former
world champion and it is quite solid so
okay we see a trade of pawns magnus
bringing his queen out so it is very
much going to transpose to a variation
of the queen's gambit to go over to the
right side and okay just a solid pawn
push
fortifying the center white bishop does
indeed leap out creating a slightly
annoying pin white dark square bishop
there just putting some pressure on the
black knight
and i expect artemia to develop his dark
square bishop as well
you've had similar positions to this one
throughout your career ivanka many times
and
well i kind of like these positions for
black i mean it's just all about picking
your plan and running with it and when
i'm talking about plan the main issue in
this position for the black pieces is
actually how they're going to develop
their light square bishop which as you
can see
is left there at home and it's stuck
there for a while and here you go you
see artemiev has decided to
go with his knight to the edge of the
board in order to trade off set of
bishops and
now after bishop takes bishop white
chooses his poison that he decides to go
for an aggressive approach and castle to
the left with this decision that he is
in that mood for a fight he doesn't just
want to play solid and defenders defend
his lead here he wants to profit from
the white pieces and okay bringing his
bishop out now and because you know that
if you castle to the opposite flank
you'll get attacked the other plan is to
actually copy white and try to castle on
this long side castle on the left and we
might well see artemis do that first he
brought a bishop out again trying to
create a pin ivanka highlighted black
light squared bishop as a problem piece
stuck behind its own pawn so it might
trade itself off later for a night very
well known but i'll tell you if he has
to commit okay first he pushes a pawn
the idea is to blunt the diagonal of the
white bishop and of the white queen
remember lining up and he's still
keeping magnus guessing actually to tuck
the rook that is sitting on the d1
square and move it to the c1 square okay
but we have seen
h
the pawn attacking the bishop and now
the bishop yep now there is a trade
parceling to the long side yes he does
that because uh there were other options
that is sitting on c3 it will go to the
edge of the board okay
and the queen actually steps forward but
there's still very much the idea of the
rook tucking itself to the c1 square
lining up against the black king and uh
all these potential night jumps and i'll
tell you if he just has to choose here
both of those moves are completely fine
he does eventually move his king closest
to that
kind of safe haven in the corner of the
board but it cost him a lot of time for
a very obvious move and okay magnus has
played maybe the most tempting option
for white
i'll tell you for sure he would have
calculated this in advance or he should
have looked at it in advance
looking at him he seems a little bit
nervy and
okay he steps forward with his queen
and how is he planning to meet magnus's
threat which is just to
push his a pawn forward and attack the
knight all those very powerful pieces
back together
yeah it does visually look impressive
and that's why the computer loves it so
much but black's position is still
rock-solid after artemis hasn't done
anything wrong and
okay so we have seen some moves on the
board let's just show this as well
because white's pawn did push forward
black's knight as well jumping into
white's half we predicted this might be
one option and then magnus actually
threatened checkmate in one move using
the queen and pawn together to try to
get to the black king so checkmate
threat on the board i'll tell you i've
said okay i've got to block it up he
pushed his ball forward bypassing
white's pawn but this guy is going to be
a thorn in black side forever now and
talking about tricky situations um
artemiev has made
maybe a mysterious rook move and uh
tucking his rook on the sea line
and i suspect that the idea is that if
the white knight jumps in to attack the
queen
that the queen won't move
and that there might be a counter attack
instead
wow okay interesting might well backfire
for white it's the most tempting move in
the position but it might backfire and
that's why magnus wow this one wasn't
even on my radar but he's put his king
in the corner and the reason he's done
this actually is not necessarily because
the king's actually safer on this square
there is an open line in front of it
memories from the season so far we've
only had the tour final left you can ask
us what he really thinks of us
of the players
how hard it is okay we have some extra
moves on the board okay so black's king
tucking itself away in the corner just
like whites has done so makes a lot of
sense also out of the eyeline of the
white queen meanwhile magnus continuing
the plan he initiated on the last turn
bringing his rook across now there is
definitely a threat against that black
knight white is threatening that knight
three times he puts the knight i mean
maybe
white can be thinking about making a
sacrifice with his own oh
okay i was thinking about sacrificing
the knight
for for for magnus and uh artemis just
says hey there's a pawn up for grabs why
don't you take it uh in the
circumstances okay white's night
dropping back that is surprising the
night came from here just what was it
three moves ago
okay what is magnus's idea
maybe he wants to start initiating play
in the center of the board maybe he
thinks that the knight has done its job
okay we will find out because black's
rook has found its most natural square
the two rooks teaming up together just
in case the position ever opens up it's
definitely a game of knights right now
white's bishop is a bit of a bystander
and oh okay magnus this is strange this
is mysterious maybe he thinks there's no
way to improve the position he takes the
time out and pushes this pawn it looks
irrelevant this move but i guess the
idea is that he's freed up his rook
they're not 100 sure so they're just
biding their time and waiting and in the
current position that has given black
the opportunity to recentralize his
knight yes very much a wait-and-see game
now it's up to magnus to come up with a
plan of improvement okay and he steps
forward with his work is this simply to
bring the other rook then behind it
potentially tag chess champs if you had
your kingdom who would be the king and
queen
c-line all four rooks
that would be maximum tension but if
magnus is playing in a more okay he does
this this is just
autopilot essentially yeah why bother
calculating any lines when you can
improve a piece contact and conflict
against your opponent's pieces while you
have one bad piece
talking about conflict david
now i mentioned it you mentioned it
right at the correct time now artemia
has made his move he's a little bit low
on the clock
and uh okay the big question is
how is magnus going to react to this
continue maneuvering he has to move the
white queen white knight or white bishop
if he doesn't want to take that black
pawn
okay he does move the white knight so as
ivanka mentioned attacking black's rook
that has forced a trade of knights and
white's bishop captures so now black's
pawn cannot really well it can step
forward to attack the white queen but it
won't be a double attack white queen
will just move out the way i i just
don't think black is much better here i
just think it's a position chances for
both sides exactly and that's what we
want yeah i guess black's hopes rely
upon the fact that he has queen and
knight and queen a knight against queen
and bishop
tends to be a pretty decent combo
now i expect white's queen to yeah yeah
pin this black born step to the side and
white has a lot of compensation uh for
this ruined pawn structure there on the
right in terms of control of the light
squares and also in a potential end game
if the queens do disappear if the rooks
disappear black's king heading towards
the center look at this actually earlier
white king went to the corner than the
black king copied now black's king has
gone back now white's king has gone back
as well both players
are definitely playing copycat just
mimicking each other there do you think
this is an indirect draw offer no no
the kings are just much better here than
they previously were okay along the
diagonals of both the queens sit on
so black is free to maybe trade if she
wants to in the center of the board
later on what kind of end games would
you have in the back of your pocket
favors the bishop with pawns on both
sides of the board but the pawn
structure is very unorthodox and okay we
do see a trade from magnus's side so
he's the one to initiate things
and i'll tell him if he's saying please
get off all the rooks please let's get
off the queens
okay he has to because his king is in so
much danger
okay so now a trade of rooks and we're
gonna see it well we're gonna see
i was gonna say trade of queens but i
spoke too soon
which is a little bit magical at times
okay queen steps back did you notice he
puts it on the same diagonal as his king
artemiev is playing in a defensive mode
but this is what he needed to do he's
badly placed if black gets two or three
moves to put that knight on a better
square i prefer black's position but uh
right now magnus has that time
um he has that small window of
opportunity to create threats himself
and the white queen actually swung
across to the center queens of great and
central squares but it had ideas on dark
square diagonal to go to the top corner
of the board actually so black has
blocked off any entry squares into his
half with that pawn push usually
isolated pawns the idea is to blockade
them and then start attacking them but
david come and look at this
magnus is trying to take a wrecking ball
to artemis
born side this should be a new one
structure is what i wanted to say yeah
and uh so he was actually giving up upon
temporarily magnus he was just trying to
open up some lines for the white queen
to use i mentioned that the white queen
needs to use a different angle a
different just a different avenue of
attack and now there has been one line
opened up the h line in the corner so
white queen could just swing across and
try to come up to the top of the board
and get to the black king from behind so
there we go the white queen does use
this new line and meanwhile the black
king steps forward and
magnus needs no asking twice he goes
forward with his queen so there is a big
threat in the position actually for the
queen to potentially swing across all
the way to the left side and start
attacking that pawn on a7 um this last
move anchor i'm slightly surprised
because black has dropped a pawn it has
the black queen is attacking white's
bishop but you can ignore it and
counter-attack and
right now the most obvious move to me
i'm trying to work out whether black has
some annoying checks but i was going to
say white's queen could have taken a
black pawn on the f6 square and
attacked the black knight david look
there's a looks like a killer move on
the board i mean it might not be killer
killer but it certainly looks incredibly
dangerous because it defends the bishop
and at the same time there is a huge
threat in the position of the queen
stepping one square backwards and
deliver a potential
yeah it's a lollies mate lollies mate
it's a nice lolly you just get it out
and well with that in the air and uh 12
seconds for our time oh he steps forward
i think he had to try something like
this ivanka just in practical terms
because he had only 20 seconds it's not
going to be 100 easy to do okay and uh
the check is on the board and now the
king no other option has to step forward
so artemia make that move
instantly but stockfish says that one
loses from blood i was tempted to go oh
he's gone he doesn't he said no no no no
the wrong way i think i thought he had
to go attack the bishop
okay so he's saying this is
close to lost yeah this looks like it's
not just in one way either white has
several opportunities here okay he does
find the safest opportunity white's
queen could have gone and grabbed a pawn
that was not human though too greedy so
he stepped back the white bishop guards
the white king a deadly threat of white
pushing one pawn forward and delivering
a david and goliath checkmates
you know all those checkmate names
ivanka
yeah okay after this last black pawn
move he has created an escape route for
the black king black's king can run back
to safety now but white just grabbed a
pawn magnus now he has a very strong
past pawn only two squares away from
becoming a new queen and artemev knows
that time is running out yeah both on
the clock and on the board he has to go
for checks he's trying to get to the
white king but white's king will find
safety on a light square it will run up
the board just like blacks has done and
there won't be any more checks so i'll
tell you if we're treating his queen but
all white needs to do now is move the
queen out of the way give a check there
we go yeah and now white pawn that
beautiful apron anna she's going to
become a queen he knows that he's just a
move or two away now from clinching it
he can push that pawn maybe he can move
the white queen first for example you
can just trade queens off the board
right now if you want to play completely
safe chess
but no he goes for a new queen first he
pushes the queen the only move that
artemis com plays is deliver a check
and
now the king is as safe as houses on
that d2 square
and uh unfortunately
anna is just simply going to go to the
eighth row and become a queen okay we
have a tricky move from artemiev he uh
puts his knight to c6 and hopefully you
know has his finger crossed that maybe
the anna will drop yeah so white's pawn
now it's promotion squares covered
black's queen is protecting it from
behind but magnus just grabbing another
pawn he actually created a pin along the
sixth rank towards the black king he's
forced the blacking even further away
right now and with this last move
carlson attacking the black queen he's
forced the black queen to take that
white pawn anna has dropped off
but
she has given up her life for a night
and white is a whole night up and that
has caused dartmouth to resign wow the
hero of the game anna wins magnus
carlsen the first game of today are
tamiya shaking his head